Excerpts from Julius Dein's latest video...
It was viewed more than 24 million times
on Facebook within the space of a few days.
Dein is only 23.
But he's already learned how to attract a
huge Internet audience with simple magic tricks.
“My dad doesn’t get it.
He doesn’t have any form of social media.
So when I told him, my video got 50 million
views on Facebook last week.
He’s like: Oh, cool, how is exams going?
This was when I first doing videos."
It all started 2 years ago.
Dein started making his first video clips
when he was an exchange student in California.
While his fellow students were doing internships,
he was working to boost his online presence.
Back home, he improved his tricks, finsihed
his course of study and devoted himself to magic.
Especially popular are the videos in which
he uses tricks to grab women's attention.
His series „HOW TO IMPRESS A GIRL WITH A
MAGIC TRICK“ has attracted almost 150 Millionen hits.
Dein performed as a magician at small parties
while still a boy.
He's come a long way since then.
These days he has 8 million facebook followers.
“ I seen your videos, men!"
“How are you doing?”
“ You are the best magician, man!”
Today, Dein is on the go near his home in
East London to try out some new tricks live.
“When I’m trying to create a video that
has 50 million views you want people giving
me good reactions.
And usually those kind of people that look
confident, look friendly, look approachable."
A few seconds later, Dein finds a good location
in front of a barber shop.
Aside from an audience, all he needs for the
trick is a marker - and some magic of course.
“Three, two, [whistles]…
boom.
X vanished.
Turn your hand over."
“What you see on the internet is a one to
five minute piece, that looks flawless, but
this things takes hours and hours and hours.
Everything from getting the right team, getting
to the right location and to learning the
right tricks, which can take ten to literally
hundreds of hours to learn."
"How long has it been since you lost your hair?"
Dein is known for pranks as well as magic
tricks.
Even his grandmother isn't safe from becoming
a target of his jokes.
With 92 million views on Facebook, this clip
set a record.
Dein is constantly monitoring what his followers
like to ensure that his next clip goes viral, too.
“Catchy introduction, huge, snappy engaging
content consistently, thumbnails, titles, not
too long, it’s a formula.
It is very important to follow the formula
how to get viral.”
The formula works. Julius Dein is the world's
most successful online magician.
But he still a long way for earning the big
bucks that the top magicians do.
“If you are looking at the biggest magician
in the world.
You’ve got David Copperfield, who made the
Statue of Liberty disappear.
You’ve got Criss Angel who walked across
the water.
I would like to create something with a huge
publicity stunt where I do stuff that takes
it up a level.
At the moment my magic doesn’t cost much
to make and I can only imagine what I could
make if I had huge budgets.”
But in the meantime Dein gets big results from
small tricks.
1.4 billion views on Facebook, Instagram, Snapchat and Youtube are certainly nothing to sneeze at.